Luke here the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here with my wife Rebecca my
friend Jake and his wife Heather and
we're doing the happy wife cold weather
challenge where we're gonna see if we
can go winter camping and remain happily
married and to do this we're bringing
the warmest camping gear known to man
we're cooking excellent food shooting
off fireworks and having a great time
[Music]
foreign
oh
all right that's a load of stuff
come on hop on
you guys good yeah
[Music]
yeah all right you ready
all right
[Music]
here
he's in the sled his hands got a little
cold they're all crammed in there like
sardines but they're warm Becca you
liking this
is loving the head
all right you ready
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
it looks like it melted a little bit oh
wow yeah yeah this is big yeah this is
their tent
yeah those will be the best ones well
Jake's breaking the big guns he's got
his canvas walled tent from his mining
claim down here so it's gonna be plenty
warm here in just a second Tom we need
to figure out where we're gonna put our
tent we need 13 feet what do you think
Tom is this a good spot let's
foreign
we shoveled a quantity of snow
comparable to a small driveway let's get
to 10.
my wife is very much yeah it looks great
I mean
and the Furious
ready
get a freaking propane
yeah we got smoke coming out of the
chimney
go on over to the top bunk
I keep
getting that's roaring
foreign
the heat rises and it gets really hot
here at the top of the hot tit so we
hang up our clothes and dry all the kids
wet clothes
how you doing well I was getting the
tent set up Tommy built a little snow
shelter
yeah
look at that
oh
that is ice right there our water jug is
Frozen oh I need
it
all right guys I think we're gonna make
some spaghetti carbonara for dinner you
like that
for dessert I got a bunch of baked
apples in this tinfoil tray and we're
gonna slide it under the stove it's
gonna take a couple hours to cook I
think
what do you guys think are you warm
Becca are you warm
oh yeah I can't believe you're still
wearing your coated here it's hot
all right guys for dinner we're making a
classic Italian Dish spaghetti carbonara
now this might seem pretty fancy but
it's not it's only five ingredients all
things you can easily bring on a camp
out a lot of these classic European
foods are really good for campouts
because they're simple ingredients and
they're non-perishable I got one of
these taken baked garlic breads I'm
gonna throw on the stove too not very
traditional but it's delicious
all right guys first thing we're gonna
do is we're gonna Brown up some bacon
I'm gonna make the sauce for the
spaghetti carbonara and it is one of the
easiest sauces in the world got five
ounces of parmigiano Reggiano basically
fancy parmesan cheese and I'm gonna need
eight eggs and then we're gonna add a
ton of pepper
then we're gonna add the bacon and the
grease here
so we just set that aside until the
pasta is done all right is there water
for boiling our pasta and you want it to
be salty I like to say that it should be
as salty as it Italians tears when you
put pineapple on pizza that's pretty
cool
how they do it do we need to microfire
all right
we're gonna bring the pasta over to
Jake's Place
yes
then we just pour the sauce
straight on let the hot noodles cook
the eggs and melt the cheese
all right that's it
lightly burned garlic bread
well there we go guys we got a moose
steak spaghetti carbonara and some
garlic bread everybody who gave birth to
a human goes first there you go here
watch here you go Jake here you go
you want some more yeah all right
whoa
there you go right here
well you made a moose carbonara sandwich
what do you think you like it excellent
what do you guys you like it
yeah it's not too bad
oh yes here here let me get you I will
take that
is an amazing news today this moose Jake
shot is amazing if you guys want to see
Jake do some crazy hunting videos check
out his Channel That's How To Alaska
I'll put a link in the video description
below the boys and they come out here
and they have it all right I gotta go do
some dishes
ah we got a scrubbing snowball
all right dinner worked out pretty good
but I think it's time for dessert
oh it smells so good in here
oh yeah
we got a little bit of granola you can
sprinkle on it too
oh nice and soft just want it just
barely keeping its shape that is good uh
I also have an apple toffee pie we gotta
warm up so we're gonna just we're gonna
put that right there we gotta have ice
cream to put on our baked apples right
yeah we're gonna make some homemade ice
cream you just need some cans of
sweetened condensed milk and a little
vanilla extract
[Music]
fresh clean snow
get the pine needles out
some lovely vanilla ice cream
okay now use some apples too
sprinkles 200 days
first piece is the ugly one hey babe
that's for you it's for me calories
don't count on campouts
it's not too bad not too shabby huh just
not Chevy at all
the baked apples it's so hard to be and
it's just apples I mean it's just it's
just apples should we do a bonfire yeah
all right let's do a bonfire doing the
dishes oh dish is all done
we're gonna get a bonfire going and see
if we can lure the ladies outside it's
pretty cold out here the nearest weather
station says it's supposed to get down
to negative nine tonight
or you know until right at the trail
Heaven's super high up
[Music]
what do you think of this fire I love it
it's a nice fire yeah that's good yeah
even Jake's coming out without his coat
what are you doing
well now that we got a big bonfire going
we need to shoot off some fireworks
if he has had enough we got tips
let's see
first of all short sword
reload reload reload reload
[Applause]
foreign
so we got this thing it's 4 000
firecrackers all wrapped up into one big
ball I think we should throw it straight
on the fire not just because it'll be
awesome but it'll be less cleanup
I'm so confuses catching on fire
oh
my goodness
that was awesome all right we got some
trash to burn
a dude I mean
it's a good time
you guys want to watch a movie before
you go to bed
okay well listen you gotta get all ready
get everything all ready get ready for
bed and then we'll watch a movie okay
somebody needs to take care of these
leftovers
there's our projector and our speaker
nice Becca bought me this little mini
portable projector just fits on a tripod
well the kids are watching their show
I'm gonna go ahead and get their beds
made up a dad's work is never done
foreign
I got all my sleeping bags set up and
the amount of Overkill in here is
ridiculous that is The Feathered Friends
negative 60 bag it's the warmest
sleeping bag in the world my wife will
sleep in that anytime it's below 40.
this right here is another negative 60
bag but it's in kids size and that's
going to be Tommy's this is a negative
25 bag Nathan's gonna use that and
that's a negative 25 bag and Jacob's
gonna sleep here than that and I've got
a North Face negative 20 bag and all of
this is ridiculous because it's like 80
degrees in this hot tet this is the
warmest tent in the world this is the
Arctic oven it's made right here in
Alaska and it is so hot in here I am
sweaty I gotta turn this down
there's expeditions to Antarctica that
aren't as well equipped as we are
all right I'm gonna go see if the kids
are done with their show
all right Jake do we need to go fetch
water we need to fetch water
oh boy
[Music]
well let's get you guys to bed okay oh
all right we're getting the boys tucked
in and I'm giving them some hot Tang
before bed
there's this little water tank on the
side of the stove the spigot on it so
you can always have hot water for hot
drinks it's kind of nice
you said you just wanted a taste there
you go my wife is going to be sleeping
in the warmest sleeping bag in the world
inside the warmest tent in the world but
that's that's not enough we're not
taking chances we're gonna go fill up
some hot water bottles that sound good
thank you it's really cold outside let's
go get her work
I've done this a time or two no
all right Bethany you're trying one of
our British water bottles
all right guys I've intruded long enough
I'll see you in the morning
oh
the company that makes this tent also
sells these fire logs they're supposed
to keep the fire burning more
consistently without having to stoke it
as often that'll keep me from having to
wake up every two hours and put wood in
the fire we're gonna see if it works
foreign
[Music]
good morning guys it's about 8 30 in the
morning and I've got breakfast almost
done put a breakfast casserole on top of
the stove that's been simmering there
for about an hour and a half for the
tent smells amazing any moment are you
warm yeah well these little logs seem to
have done the trick I used only three of
them for the entire night and apparently
they work really good for cooking as
well because it makes a nice even Flame
like it
that's one of the better nights I've had
camping I was warm and I slept pretty
well good I'm glad
there we go
this is the last winter that it was
gonna we've got Caribou sauces this is
your Caribou you shot yeah Cody shot it
nice this trip is turning into a mammal
sampler platter
that oh
and we got some leftover breakfast pie
yep breakfast five
that's for you oh that's amazing
all right here's the casserole it's a
whole thing of tater tots with some
reindeer sausage some Jimmy Dean sausage
some peppers onions cilantro and green
peppers on top just made it up all
beforehand and just put it on the stove
when we were ready to start cooking it
I feel like sunny side up
did you like the casserole I love it
yeah it's good what do you think Mom is
good the green onions in the cilantro
that's what make it the salt not the
shakes
[Music]
that looks really good all right I'm
gonna try Caribou sausage too
the boys want to go on the snow machine
so we gotta get them all bundled up
foreign
did you enjoy that
yeah
well the boys are running around on snow
machines and Becca's warm I think it's
time for me to start making some lunch
real quick what are you making food yeah
all right guys we're gonna make El
Salvadorian pupusas I got one bag with
refried beans cheese and jalapeno and
this one with corn flour
foreign
[Music]
beans squeeze that into a disc and grab
off the excess
[Music]
here what are these These are pupusas
they're El Salvadorian and they're
gluten-free you had a little jalapeno
refried beans cheese really simple
ingredients really almost like the
flavor of a tamale but better texture I
kind of think of it as like an El
Salvadorian grilled cheese sandwich okay
they eat it with pickled cabbage there
you go
bitched it and came back
you got lunch in our belly I think it's
uh I think it's time to start cleaning
up a little bit
oh I'll tell you what me and Becca
really like this article of intent if
you guys want to find out more
information about it I'll put a link
down in the video description below
if you're wondering what our toilet
situation is here we have this little
toilet seat that we bought that fits
onto a five gallon bucket and when
you're not using it you put it outside
and all the bad stuff freezes then we go
and burn it
foreign
[Music]
we got a minute or two you want to ride
on the snow machine together yeah just
go nice and slow nice and slow
all right that's good right there
foreign
have you stayed warm I've stayed warm
good well we're all packed up and I
think we need to start snow Machining
back
you look good on a snow machine babe
this is really fun I really enjoyed that
foreign
did we keep you warm we can't be warm
our marriage is intact it's fine good
all right well let's get headed home
we made it back home and I'm drying out
the tent and all of our gear and it's
been a great trip and we had a good time
Becca stayed warm and I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning all right I'll see you
guys next Saturday bye-bye if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching